let's see if we can write 0.36 as a fir
action as a fraction and there are
several ways of doing it the way I like
to do it is to say well 0.36 this is the
same thing as 36 hundredths or one way
to think about it is this is in the
hundreds place hundreds hundreds place
this is in the tens place or you could
view this as 30 hundredths you could
view this as three tenths or thirty
hundreds so we could say that this is
the same thing as thirty six hundredths
or this is equal to thirty six over one
hundred we've already expressed it as a
fraction but now we could actually
simplify it because both 36 and
one-hundred have some common factors
they are both divisible by well looks
like they're both divisible by four so
if we could divide the numerator by 4
and the denominator by 4 we get we're
doing the same thing to both so we're
not changing the value of the fraction
36 divided by 4 is 9 and then 100
divided by 4 is 25 and now these two
characters don't seem to share any other
common factors and so we've written it
we've written it in simplified form and
we're done